and then I will be back I think I'm
going to do a look back at one of my
first viral videos for the next one
maybe something people got mad at me for
so look forward to that thank you for
watching that video was published I
think seven months ago eight months ago
maybe now and no video has come out so
I'm here to finally make that video on
the second channel I want to respond to
my thoughts on the school of life
because they have changed drastically
but the video is up presenting my ideas
as if I still agree with said video and
I think it actually can be useful rather
than just taking down the video and no
one knows why I got taken down I can
maybe respond to some of those points
and Link this video to that video so
people can see you know how or why I
might have changed my mind
so to understand my framework of
thinking when I was making that video I
was a youtuber with 300 subscribers and
I was just I saw the school of life
having such a massive audience as a
problem because I thought wow I probably
could do that better they seem super
biased they have this name that says
they're unbiased they kind of they say
they're uh Nydia logical and really they
are ideological look sitter excited
cetera so I was kind of you know mad
about that and I wrote sort of a
polemical piece against their channel
very critical of their channel as you
know so that video blew up I had no idea
would blow up and there's no way I could
have predicted that otherwise I would
have done it a long time ago probably
and for a while I like everything was
great but slowly my when I would revisit
the video every now and then I would
notice some things that I didn't quite
agree with anymore and I want to share
those so so this right here I think you
can see that is my three critiques of
the school of life they pretend to be
unbiased they sell a shallow view of
philosophy and they are basically
money-grubbers there are profit ears as
I say well revisiting that video as a
creator with some amount of stature now
in some some amount of reputation
i-i see it from a completely different
angle and all I'll say is that it's one
thing to be a critic and it's another
thing to be someone who's participating
in the same field that the School of
Life is for example which is being a
YouTube creator and I'm a lot more
sympathetic to their problems so the
first point is that they pretend to be
unbiased this is all stemming from their
channel trailer which I don't think
should be the channel trailer for the
record that says they are an
unidentified that to be quite untrue and
as I point out the school of life which
sounds like it's an organization of
unbiased truth-tellers maybe like a
philosophy course is more along to
Bhutan's perspectives on philosophy and
emotional intelligence and I don't think
it's that big of a deal in hindsight so
long as the viewers aware of that I
think they probably should pick another
channel trailer but it's not the biggest
crime in the world my name is
coffee-break and I'm just a guy I mean
mostly I have like a small team like
Ilan does but I'm mostly the scripts are
written by me most of the perspectives
and the ideas are mine and you might get
confused coming to coffee break thinking
oh this is like some poor big
organization but it's not it's just me
and so now now that I have that
perspective of you just choose a name at
a certain point you just stick with that
name and you get popular and people can
criticize you but it was just the name
you picked at the beginning when you had
no idea what it was so yes he's biased
but so are all of us secondly I say that
I say that their philosophy is bad and I
point to a few videos a couple videos I
think the mind-body problem and I think
that they made a pop approach to some of
either Socrates or Plato as ideas and
well I think this is fair I mean they
got they definitely got the mind-body
problem wrong I think that casting all
of their work into the dustbin just
because they got one thing wrong is a
little unfair and it's definitely
definitely selective editing I mean
they've done good pieces before and yeah
I've just seen I've seen my buddy Austin
McConnell get trashed because he made
one mistake on a hearthstone video and
after seeing that I realized that you
can't just discount somebody's work just
because they made one mistake
I mean people making YouTube videos
under a time crunch will make mistakes
it happens it's not the end of the world
they should be held accountable but it's
not the end of the world and as for
their whole sort of making Plato into a
love doctor I think yes that's kind of
dumb sort of cheapens it but if that's
who they want to appeal to that's who
they want to appeal to like I said my
perspective is just drastically changed
now that I am a creator because I'm
familiar with the challenges of being a
creator and I'm much more sympathetic I
don't just look at the school of life
and be like what would I have made the
school of life if I had two million
subscribers or however many million
subscribers they have I'm now acquainted
with the trade offs I as coffee break
cannot make an infinitely nuanced video
as much as I'd like to on the cigarettes
gambling and other things that aren't
addictive that video for example had
pages and pages that I had to cut
because it wasn't interesting to the
layman and I'm appealing to the
layperson I'm not appealing to addiction
experts or to gambling experts I'm
appealing to the laymen so I have to
cater it to the layman and so some of
that nuance has to leave it doesn't mean
I didn't think of it it doesn't mean
that I didn't care about it or research
it or care to get the facts right it's
just I have to appeal to the lame and I
think that's what they were doing and
then finally that their profit ears this
one - yeah totally reversed my position
on it because I'm now familiar with the
fact that when you're doing something
you love it does not you don't make a
ton of money from YouTube you don't you
have to find ways to monetize whether
that be through sponsorships like I've
started to do or through merch like the
school of life does that I criticize
them so heavily for yeah I don't know
there's not much to say there I think my
takeaway from the school of life and the
problem with the school of life
they'd of it is that from an outsider
perspective it's very easy to
deconstruct people who have done work
and deconstruct it from a certain
perspective and say it's all bad because
look at it when I take it apart and put
it into its little pieces but what's a
lot harder than deconstructing because
that's easy what's a lot harder than
deconstructing is constructing something
and making it better and I hope you know
that that's what I tried to do with
coffee break with the success that I've
been given I'll be it my first big video
was the School of Life which was a
criticism I haven't done many since then
because I'm not I'm not that interested
in criticisms except insofar as they
kind of serve a larger point and serve
some grander point and in that case my
video wasn't serving much of a bigger
point other than to kind of explain why
I found their channel to be so
distasteful but I did not teach anybody
anything I did not contribute to you
know sort of the lame and understanding
philosophy other than to trash someone
else who was so in hindsight not a not
my favorite video that I've ever made
and I disagree now now that I'm a
creator I disagree with most of the
points that I made all of the points
really that I made in that video I think
they're true to an extent but ultimately
fall short and should not be held
against the school of life so that is
the video just for your knowledge I
never have made any money from the
School of Life video it was claimed and
I still will not make money as I keep it
up because as of right now unless the
community wants me to take it down I
will not be taking that video down it
doesn't get a lot of views and I think
it could serve as sort of an instructive
piece on how people's minds change over
time and how that can be not reflected
in their work because YouTube still
serving up that video like I I made it a
day ago when in reality that's almost
two years ago and I've gained a lot of
perspective and had a lot to think about
since then and I'm in the middle of a
big project right now with a lot of
research and a lot of just kind of
coming through some some books and yeah
I'm hoping to construct something you
will find valuable in this next video so
uh yeah I hope you have a lovely new
year see ya
[Music]